being here four years in a row now I
sort of feel and I want to brag but I
feel like I become kind of a comic-con
expert you know I do okay first thing
you do like to brag secondly really yes
I really believe this when it comes to
comic books superhero movies sci-fi
fantasy and all things comic-con I
believe and I believe this sincerely
there is literally no bigger expert than
this guy right here then you should have
no problem passing the just invented
comic-con citizenship test administered
by the star of Halloween the scream
queen herself Jamie Lee Curtis
[Applause]
it's an honor it is indeed an honor I'm
a little afraid right now but I'm
confident that I can do this Conan Conan
Conan I know that you think you have
street cred here at comic-con but I beg
to differ and I will administer a very
simple test and we will see how you do
thinking that you know all there is to
know about comic-con okay I think I'm
ready let's do ready yes I am ready okay
I'm a little scared but I'm ready okay
well you should be alright there we go
first question what is black widows real
name Natasha Romanoff
what type of crystal do you need to
build a lightsaber fiber crystal in the
new Aquaman movie what does Jason Momoa
ride an extremely satisfied sea dragon
the are are in george RR martin stands
for really rich the Jedi mind-trick can
I help people forget they paid to see
solo
what good doctor strange used to be
known as medical resident peculiar
when Catwoman retires she'll become cat
lady named all the Infinity stone the
space stone the reality stone the Emma
Stone the Sharon Stone the Oliver Stone
these sly in the Family Stone and the
Cold Stone Creamery Stone
why can't the Millennium Falcon
actually make a Kessel run in 12 parsecs
as a parsec is a unit of distance not of
time and what is the thing you just did
call it's called Haun's planing do your
impression of Groot having an
existential crisis am i Groot
Bruce Wayne was driven as a
twelve-year-old to a life of darkness
and revenge by personally witnessing his
parents doing it this year comic-con
starts on July 19th and this year
comic-con end when someone is spotted
cosplaying John Travolta in dotty named
the three most endured
all right I'm sorry I beg your pardon I
was hamming it up a bit and I apologize
again again please
I will cuz this is the most important
question okay name the three most
enduring horror movie franchises okay
Halloween a night a Nightmare on Elm
Street and Friday the 13th
now name their porn parodies
hallo-weiner a wet dream on sex Street
and Friday the 69
you're doing quite well thank you thank
you thank you very much
Aquaman star Jason Momoa is from Hawaii
and Momoa is a Hawaiian word that means
momo it's animals are something you want
mo of and what is it the audience saying
about this bit please no mo uh who is
the most despicable villain in the DC
Universe that would be Mitch McConnell
what's dr. Strange's deepest to darkest
secret his doctorate is from an online
university the big question that
millennial fans of Doctor Who usually
ask what's a phone booth
[Laughter]
what does Wonder Woman's lasso do chase
finish this phrase with great power
comes great three I am rambling tirades
on Twitter
what is Deadpool's greatest regret
playing the Green Lantern
what is the hulk's only weakness the
fall shoe sale at Nordstrom's
what do a condom and Hall H badge have
in common they both help nerdy men get
inside an exclusive corridor once a year
and finally what is the greatest team of
superheroes ever assembled well that's
easy the men and women who bravely stood
in line to be in this
[Applause]
[Music]
you've all been in school you know the
teacher goes like this yeah quiet I am
going to give you an award because you
are you are an expert you are a champion
of comic-con thank you and I'm giving
you my all-access comic-con pass with my
name on it
so oh my god
you
you